thank you very much uh mata thank you  very much for convening this important  meeting and  therefore i'm very happy to be here  today to witness the action you are  taking here as four countries with uh  the memorandum you've signed which  indeed is a very strong political  commitment from your countries to making  the north sea europe's green power plan  now how do we make it a success  as policy makers we can definitely help  by setting very clear targets that is  for predictability for the investment  by removing bottlenecks and by  de-risking private investment  on all these points the european union  is moving forward this was the package  we power eu that the commission has  presented today  our plan is to rapidly reduce our  dependency on russian fossil fuels by  really fast forwarding the clean energy  transitions so last but not least the  more  interdependent we become in europe  the more independent we become from  russia  you